ich möchte gerne über kroner sprechen
denn gerade steigende infektionszahlen
wenn es wieder überall in allen medien
die infektionszahlen steigen das gefühl
die panik steigt schon wieder in der
bevölkerung auf jeden fall auch im
bekanntenkreis nie wird wieder über die
infektionszahlen gesprochen ich bin das
thema sehr leid habe mir aber einmal
angeschaut inwiefern die
infektionszahlen mit blick auf die
altersgruppen steigen und was man
definitiv feststellen kann ist dass in
den letzten zwei monaten signifikant bei
den älteren gruppen also 80 die
infektions eingestiegen sind es ist
nicht die gruppe wo es am meisten
gestiegen ist aber die sind signifikant
gestiegen in den letzten zwei monaten
und da muss ich natürlich sagen da
sollten wir schon hin schauen wir haben
es letzten winter nicht geschafft die
alten zu beschützen wir haben es nicht
geschafft dass die heime sicher waren
und es hätte schon christian lind hat
sehr früh darauf hingewiesen dass man
die wohlhabenden gruppen besser schützen
soll ich glaube auch dass eine gute
strategie früher in ein heim hätte sein
müssen und dementsprechend würde ich
sagen der winter steht bevor wir sollten
jetzt aber wirklich darauf achten dass
bei dem 80 jährigen definitiv ist nicht
wieder aufkommt weil das ist eigentlich
die einzige kennziffer wo es wirklich
noch gefährlich werden kann sind die
gruppen in den altersgruppen nena ich
geb dir absolut recht damit ich habe bei
jedem deiner setze eben gedacht haken
haken habe aber das haben wir haben doch
letztes jahr gesehen dass genau das
gegenteil passierte dürfte es nicht
darüber spreche man hat das gefühl
gehabt wenn man sich traut anzusprechen
so wir haben gruppen die sind
verwundbarer als andere die müssen
anders geschützt werden wir vielleicht
in einer intensität die ist auch nötig
macht dass sie auch mal anders zu hause
bleiben sage ich mal ist der rest der
gesellschaft du wurdest jedes mal wenn
ich das angemerkt habe gab es erstmal
einen auf den deckel vor william webb
solchen deckel wenn man sich medial
geäußert hat würde ich jetzt kein
nein also was wir brauchen natürlich
schon die berühmten booster impfung über
die jetzt gerade widerspricht wir
sollten auch ernsthaft über konzepte
debattieren wie wir die eltern schützen
können ohne direkt in irgendeiner ecke
geschoben zu werden ihr wollt die alten
ausschließen weil ganz beliebt jetzt
dass er kein mensch will irgend jemanden
ausschließen aber so als auch nicht
gehen nichtsdestotrotz ja die zahlen
steigen wieder aber bitte bitte nicht
wieder diese panikmache beten nicht vor
dem wind jetzt wieder hingehen wir haben
fast 80 prozent sind durchgeimpft
nein er kann einfach nicht sein wir
haben eine hochgradig entspannte
situation was wir brauchen ist alles
andere als eine diskussion wie wir jetzt
wieder maßnahmen ergreifen was wir
brauchen sind eine bessere perspektiven
müssen beim freedom day sprechen es geht
nicht mehr an das ist auch nicht mehr
anders zu recht sehr wichtig wir müssen
aufpassen mit solchen waren rufen da
geht es wieder ganz schlimm zu fallen
bei den alten die müssen wir schützen
altenheime dann sind wir schnell wieder
bei einer diskussion
will es nur weiter zeichnen da kommt
doch sofort herr lauterbach um die ecke
und plädiert für den nächsten log
downloads für den walk down von
altenheimen darüber sind wir hinweg es
müssen booster impfung kommen und
ansonsten freiheit die frage auf die wir
uns eigentlich schon verständigt hatten
wie stark sind die krankenhäuser
belastet die intensivstation da mag es
ja so und so viel neue infizierte geben
aber das ist doch längst nicht mehr so
gefährlich wie es mal war
aber das problem ist doch auch eins wenn
wir das politisch betrachten dass spd
und union in kosten kennen wir warum
haben denn die grünen und die fdp in
diesen verhandlungen kein wort bislang
über corona verloren warum dann hat
christian lindner ist nicht zu seinem
thema gemacht auch in diesen
sondierungsgesprächen zu sagen mit mir
gibt es eine andere politik rus warum er
am ende gewählt wo das ganz wichtig zu
sagen finde ich hatte gar dsl weiter
wächst zweistellig geworden als einziger
in einem demokratischen spektrum eine
politik vertreten hat die auf freiheit
auch der grundrechte aber auch cholera
hat jetzt aktuell herz gesagt ich frage
mich wieso macht die ampel corona nicht
zu einem thema und sozusagen schneidet
damit auch all denjenigen das wort ab
jetzt in der spd sagen wir müssen wieder
ein locker machen das ist jetzt die
verantwortung von dieser ampel wir sind
halt taktiker und sie wollen ganz am
ende wenn unterschrieben wird irgendwas
müssen reinschreiben zur
gesundheitspolitik da führt kein weg
dran vorbei aber das wollen sie erst in
der letzten runde festlegen irgendwann
im dezember wenn sie einschätzen können
was um sie herum los ist und sie wissen
doch wenn sie was liberalisieren des
reinschreiben fängt sofort karl
lauterbach in allen talkshows an dagegen
zu rebellieren und sie haben eine
diskussion innerhalb der koalition die
sie nicht wollen du hast völlig recht
ist es die reine taktiererei es ist
nicht klare haltung die fdp könnte dass
sie hat es nämlich den ganzen sommer
über schon getan aber sie tut es halt
nicht weil sie andere ziele hat sie will
das finanzministerium haben und darum
geht es hier so und ein bisschen
digitalisierung und jetzt wird viel über
die alten gesprochen und wir verlieren
wieder die jungen aus dem blick die
kinder was würde passieren bei einem
neuen lockt an die schulen würden
schließen und die schulden sind jetzt ja
schon kann ort der freude mehr für die
kinder die grundschüler sitzen mit
masken im raum den ganzen tag kriegen
schlecht luft die brillen beschlagen das
ist wirklich eine zumutung und darüber
spricht kein mensch also ich verstehe
immer noch nicht dass das in der
politischen debatte so unter die planer
in der werbung hatte das ja mal eine
zeit lang auch im wahlkampf zum thema
gemacht die situation von kindern hat
cooler master an das finde ich ja das
geniale ring und stellen sich hin und
sagen menschenrechte achtet bitte auf
die freiheitsrechte aber eigentlich
wollten sie die ghs maßnahmen das
vergisst man bei den grünen aber die
grünen waren mir ist ein heißer sommer
eine diskussion im bundestag in
erinnerung als die fdp beantragt hat
diese pandemische lage zu beenden denn
das bedeutet dass in der elemente außer
kraft gesetzt und dann taten also die
sprecher der anderen fraktionen rund
nach einer nach dem anderen auf und
plädierte für die eigene entmachtung und
zwar auch die grünen sind die verrückt
danach wie geht das wirklich so ja ja
die schaffens gegen sich selbst zu
demonstrieren das finde ich auch mal
besonders lustig einigen grün ja gut
aber die grünen ich finde also noch
einmal da ist jetzt die parteien der
verantwortung die am lautesten
aufgetreten er das in der opposition als
partei die dafür steht und ich frage
mich wieso sagen die nicht zumindest mal
irgendetwas dazu alles was man von
christian lindner hört sind irgendwie
staatstragende reden die keiner hören
will also ich zumindest nicht wo er
nichts sagt über gar nix er könnte doch
jetzt mal sagen ich stehe zu meinem wort
ich stehe dazu zu unseren
freiheitsrechten und ich werde
durchsetzen dass das so nicht weitergehe
würde ja schon reichen oder kubicki
losschickt ich mein erstes als künftiger
finanzminister bewegt er ja schon
bemerkte ja jeder satz wird auf die
goldwaage gelegt was bedeutet das für
die europäischen märkte wäre es doch gut
wenn die handy
das war nicht so genau muss man
natürlich schon sehen ich meine die
ampel zu machen ich finde christian
linder ist das schon ein sehr gutes
stück gelungen man erkennt ganz klar die
liberale handschrift in seinen jungs am
4 ich muss da schon sagen können wozu
der wieder einmal christian lindner hat
schon guten job gemacht und ich finde
schon und die rede übrigens bei den
sondierungsgesprächen paar wurde olaf
scholz stein annalena baerbock stein sei
es gestand da muss ich sagen fand ich
seine ruhige art und wie er da geredet
hat fand ich exakt angemessen es ging
mir überhaupt nicht aber trotzdem sollen
ja ja das ist ein problem bin ich total
bei das kreide ich auch lieber christian
lindner bitte mehr über krone
ja das ist aber ein wunsch aber trotzdem
muss man sagen er hat seine rolle gut
gemacht
nicht das gefühl eines legt wieder ein
absolut aber was mich interessieren
würde aus ihrer sicht die union dann in
der opposition wie wird die sich beim
thema corona verhalten also wird man da
sozusagen den merkel kurs irgendwie hat
er beim schütteln oder wird man wird man
weiter sagen 'ja ja bloß vorsichtig man
wird herr ich befürchte man wird auf
dieser vor sich zwar weiter herumreißt
das muss ich jetzt zu sagen weil es mir
einfach so gegen den strich geht ich
habe die liberalen letztes jahr wirklich
lieben gelernt allein wegen ihren gewinn
auf also das sage ich nicht
ich habe ich war so dankbar dass sie
letztes jahr die einzigen waren die mit
so einer vehemenz und einer überzeugung
aufgetreten sind das kritisch
hinterfragt haben was man dringend
kritische den ausfall mit cdu
zweitstimme
[Gelächter]
die kreuzfahrt denken - gelungen aber es
stimmt schon mit coruna ist muss man
schon ganz klar sagen was da passiert
ist ist wirklich schlimm deswegen ist
mir heute auch wichtig war über die
infektionszahlen zu reden bevor wir die
große panik mache kommt bei uns wurde
schon die freiheit also ich habe es als
freiheitsentzug empfunden das sage ich
auch immer besser das wundert mich nicht
also ich glaube keiner wenn dein auto
fahren im alltag stellen geworden ist
durch seine eigene partei wird nicht
minister dann wird die union in einem
reflex der opposition die ängstliche im
inland organisieren die ängstlichen sind
die eltern die die maske gar nicht
ablegen wollen das heißt sie wird immer
feuer und mord schreien dass söder hat
ja schon angefangen das ist alles falsch
was da jetzt passiert so wird sie
weiterhin auf
damit die jungen eher meinten dagegen es
kann also dachte ich wirklich gern
welche seiten sie in ein freies spiel
ich bin ja gerade sie wählen dann weiter
sagen toller kurs und ansonsten niemand
etwas sagen darauf zwei verschiedene
fragen ja also holler kurs nein
drinbleiben jara isla beantwortet
[Musik]